what up space fam goes in here for anime
uproar and today we're going to be talk
about every type of quirk in my hero
academia if you didn't know all quirks
can be placed into specific categories
and we're going to be discussing those
fascinating categories today if you
enjoyed seeing MHA videos on this
channel and want to see more make sure
the united states of smash that like
button and share this video with a
friend because they're really helpful to
youtube algorithm if you haven't be sure
to subscribe and this is crucial hit
that notification bell or else you won't
know when future videos come out for
more MHA content and important updates
about the new season you can follow us
on twitter and instagram at anime uproar
there will be manga spoilers in this
video so that bothers you you've been
warned now without further ado let's
jump into it let's recap some basics
about quirks before we start getting
fancy as we know quirks are super powers
in the my hero academia world quirks
appeared one day in the form of glowing
baby and before you knew it around 80%
of the world's population possessed a
quirk it's been theorized that quirks
were actually the result of a virus
carried by mice wow if only our own
world was that convenient mice carrying
viruses are nowhere near as fun in our
world also we are told that quirks will
just get stronger and stronger with
subsequent generations with each new
generation quirks blend and evolve and
there will come a day when these complex
overpowered quirks will be impossible
for individuals to control this specific
theory is called the quirk singularity
doomsday theory sometimes kids will
manifest a quirk from one of the parents
or a composite work like Totoro keys
that combines the father's quirk with
the mother's quirk more rarely a quirk
will manifest that is now related to the
child's genetic lineage so we might
describe this as a rare mutation and
Aries rewind quirk and Shingen Aki's the
cake work are examples of this okay now
let's look at the three main types of
quirk categories and then some other
interesting the less official categories
the three main types are known as
emitter transformation and mutant an
emitter type quirk also known as an
activation type Court allows its user to
activate and release substances like
Todoroki with fire knives or certain
effects like Aizawa with erasure the
emitter type user's body doesn't
transform in any significant way and
their powers have to be
activated although the activation is not
always conscious in other words with
emitter types their quirks are not
always visible in contrast to mutant
types which we'll get to later even
people who look like mutants aka they
don't look like normal humans can have
emitter type quirks rather than mutant
type quirks
for example Mina looks like a pink alien
Koji has a stranger shaped head and
fumika guy looks like chicken Batman
they all seem to have permanent quirks
that make them look different but
they're actually all emitter types and
their physical appearances really don't
have anything to do with their actual
quirks how can we explain this well at
some point their ancestors develop
mutant type quirks that made them look
different from humans and these physical
characteristics were passed down even
though they were no longer directly
related to the descendant specific work
thus Mina's real quirk is acid now
looking like a pink alien and fumika
gaze as dark shadow not looking like
chicken Batman some more examples of
emitter type quirks include baka ghouls
explosion and communities
electrification one produces explosions
and the other produces electricity other
emitter type quirks can produce effects
rather in substances like Aizawa
produces an effect that can suppress
emitter and transformation type quirks
one for all is also considered an
emitter type quirk when you look at all
might it could seem like a
transformation type quirk at first but
his transformation from skinny to
muscular doesn't seem to be a feature of
the quirk for instance that koo doesn't
suddenly become puffed up when he uses
it the quirk initially allows deku to
produce an effect that enhances his
physical abilities although there's more
to it and we'll get to that later
next let's look at transformation type
quirks as the name suggests these quirks
allow their users to transform their
otherwise normal-looking body sometimes
the quirk enhances the existing body
parts like kitty Shima with his
hardening ability and sometimes the
quirk adds new features to the body like
the quick tool arms which lets the
chainsaw gnome will produce new limbs
with chain saws at the ends of them and
he can retract them too usually
transformation quirks only affect the
user but there is an interesting
exception the student from Shi ketsu
high school called Seiji shishah kuda
can use his meatball quirk to transform
his own body as well as the bodies of
other people he can turn others into
balls of flesh transformation type
quirks are also known as hybrid
quirks because they seem to combine the
need to be activated with the mutant
shaped appearance of mutant type queries
unlike mutant quirks though these
powerful transformation type quirks lead
to overexertion in the user and
eventually the user gets at a point
where they can no longer maintain their
transformation we've seen this with
Kirishima and Tatsu Tatsu who
specifically needs to consume enough
iron to maintain his steel form the
really cool ninja hero edge shot has a
transformation type quirk Fulda body he
has trained and refined his quirk to
such an extent that he is able to
transform his body faster than the speed
of sound some other notable
transformation quirk users are dragoon
hero Luke you with her dragon quirk
mount lady with her Giganta fication
quirk Tamaki with his manifest quirk
medial with his permeation quirk
hemoccult Olga with her transform quirk
and big sis Kendall with her big fist
quirk
as previously mentioned the last of the
official three core categories is called
mutant mutant quirks are associated with
the user's physical mutations these
quirks are always visible and as a
result always active in a sense because
mutant quirks still need to be activated
Aizawa z racial quirk will not erase
appendages that are associated with
mutant type quirks
for example mezzo Shoji's mutant type
quirk do plie arms gives him tentacles
alongside his arms these tentacles can
be made to replicate other body parts
like ears or eyes
although Aizawa in theory could stop the
replication of other body parts he
cannot make the tentacles themselves
disappear because they are ever present
even when Shoji is resting some other
mutant type quirks include EDA's engine
quirk or gyros tail quirk zeros earphone
jack work and Ibanez ozaki's vines quirk
the effects of these quirks can be
similar to that of emitter type quirks
for instance Giro's quirk can release
south to shatter the ground around her
or hurt her opponents but the difference
is that the physical manifestation of
her earphone jack work can't be turned
off so to speak a lot of people have
asked what would happen if I saw I used
his erasure quirk on toaru kagaku days
mutant type quirk called invisibility
which she suddenly become visible in my
view it is unlikely that iowa could
cancel out the effect because
invisibility appears to be always active
even when Todd was supposed to be asleep
or unconscious just like metal Shoji's
tentacles
the invisibility appears to be a
physical
a station of her quark that cannot be
turned off an interesting example of a
mutant type Court is Principal nez's
hi-spec quark this was a rare case where
a quark manifested in an animal
he's a mutated animal whose query
granted him superior intelligence and
allows him to live in human society
those are the three official core
categories and pretty much all quirks
can be placed into one of the three
categories however we can also
categorize quirks in some different ways
for instance there are accumulation type
quirks these quirks require the
accumulation of something to be
activated
examples are Aries rewind quirk fat gums
fat absorption quark and Dec whose
one-for-all quirk for fat gum if he
absorbs the force behind enemy attacks
he can release the accumulated force
back in the form of one powerful punch
one for all stockpiles powers and
accumulates quirks from its previous
users the user can focus that stockpile
power in one body part or spread it out
evenly in order to achieve superhuman
power and speed as a result every
subsequent user gets stronger and
stronger since it allows the user to
eventually use all the quirks of past
users we could also include one for all
in an interesting category of quirks
that allow their users to use multiple
quirks technically these quirks become a
part of the one for all quark so it's
still one overarching quirk but
nonetheless in effect it allows that goo
to use what appear to be unrelated
quirks total rookies have cold half hot
quark is like this too since there's one
quirk allows him to use fire core powers
and I squirt powers similarly NATO
monomers copy quirk allows him to copy
and use multiple quirks although he
cannot use them simultaneously he has to
switch back and forth for the time being
there are more characters whose quirks
could be included in this category such
as chemical toga since her quirks
awakened
speaking of awaken quirks that could
also be a category we use it is possible
when the quirk users are pushed to
extreme life-and-death situations that
their quirks can undergo an evolution
this has been called a quirk awakening
in togas case her quirk used to let her
physically transform into people if she
consumed their blood however since the
quirk awakened she can now use those
people's quirks to similarly during his
fight against rhe destro she got Aki's
quirk underwent an awakening shigaraki
blue
the previous limits of his decay quirk
and pretty much destroyed an entire city
as if the league of villains weren't
Opie enough twice also appears to have
undergone an awakening in order to save
toga he blows past his limits
before he was limited to two duplicates
of things at a time and he wouldn't
clone himself because of his mental
instability however he broke past this
limit and used a move called infinite
doubles where he creates clones of
himself and the clones create clones and
so on and so on as the attacks name
suggests he could in theory create
infinite doubles and it's been said that
twice as quick now has the potential to
take down entire countries arguably yuzu
Koo began the awakening process when he
unlocked the new quirk black whip but he
still has plenty more quirks from past
one for all users to awaken and that is
it for today's video
we have discussed the official three
categories and some specific and
fascinating unofficial categories of
quirks that I thought would be fun to
look at if you enjoyed this video make
sure to United States have smash that
like button and share this video with a
friend if you haven't be sure to
subscribe and this is crucial
hit that notification bell because you
won't know when future videos come out
if you don't
for more MH a content and important
updates on new seasons follow us on
twitter and instagram at anime uproar a
special thank you goes out to our
patrons on patreon who help us survive
YouTube issues and who helped make
videos like this one possible I
especially want to thank our pro hero
tier patrons the one and only Gilgamesh
nothing but a fan Jason Wilson Kings ell
dress fitted ala beat Anatole cos ASCII
alpha do angel Cruz and team Sparky 65
and are the one tier patrons the ones
who stand atop all clans Steven n grata
a lull on attempt Matty Mac 239
makoto-kun the world Steelers Tyson
Kirino and the school bus thank you all
so much if you enjoy our work you can
support more of it by going over to
patreon calm an Emir Pro and becoming a
patron today for as little as $1 if you
do so you'll get your name featured in
future videos alongside these amazing
people right here and you'll even get
access to our private patron only
discord where we talk about anime life
and of course dank memes so check out
patreon.com/lenguin
you can also now join the YouTube
channel and support more content that
way if you prefer
whichever way you choose to support us
you can get the same great benefits
until next time see you space cowboy
[Music]
you
[Music]